this is Startalk hello welcome to
Startalk live very special edition from
san francisco's Sketchfest it is my
great honor to bring on your guest host
for this evening
the amazing Bill Nye the Science Guy
be seated please love that song love
that song ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls kids of all ages you're in for the
the greatest two hours of radio you've
ever watched it's not quite toots gonna
make that about that so it's great to
see you all thank you so much for coming
I am here on behalf of my beloved dear
colleague Neil deGrasse Tyson he's
working cosmos but tonight we are gonna
talk about some serious business the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
and you could say well that's crazy or
you could say it's serious business and
to that end we have the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence Institute
the SETI Institute senior astronomer
give it up for mr. Seth Shostak
oh you know it says and then as though
it's not funny enough people a former
colleague co-worker of mine for those of
you who never miss an episode of
Stargate Atlantis from kids in the hall
Dave Foley
so gentlemen you're to day she's not
made of stone Dave take it easy take it
easy of course she's wild for you no
it's great to see you all and we're
gonna talk about something very serious
and remarkable and cool and something
that in my opinion which as you know is
correct
well dare I say it change the world
there are two questions - questions deep
within us - questions each and every one
of you has asked at some point in his or
her life where did we come from and well
that's pretty close but those of you
listening on the radio he said why are
we here and I think this is a sketch
fast and you bought admission ticket and
you can't then take that up to the
people you're sitting with where do we
come from and are we alone and if you
meet somebody who says I've never asked
those questions they're lying okay so
it's it's an exciting time and this is
something that goes back all of my
academic life I'm talking about since
somewhat before kindergarten I've
wondered these questions and we have
here a guy that really tries to answer
this question for real Seth Dave Foley
so Seth what is it you do exactly
video ladies calm down there's no video
we're trying to find out if there are
any cosmic confreres if there's any
cosmic company out there not just alien
snot just pond scum on Mars dead or
alive
but are there any people or things or
Klingons or intelligences there are at
least as clever as you know the average
resident of the Bay Area
so how would we go about are you looking
for the Grateful Dead in space you know
I need a miracle yeah I've heard you can
get juggling sticks in Alpha Centauri so
you have it can you get tickets to the
eugene show ok so Seth how do you go
about actually looking for actual
extraterrestrial intelligence actually
alright this is something you can use at
your next cocktail party there are only
three ways to look for aliens that were
using today one is to just go there and
try and find them that only works if
you're going nearby I mean you might go
to Mars and maybe you find pond scum but
on the other hand you probably go to
your bathroom and find pond scum that's
one way the second way is build really
big telescope and look at the light
coming from some planet around some
godforsaken others star split up that
light with a prism look at that is this
getting too technical and and then not
yet all right what is this prism Yutaka
are you saying prison wrong you're
flashing lights frighten me it's a
common enough word in California you
split it up with a prism and then you
look for things like oxygen or methane
that's right this room used to have 21%
of the air in this room used to be
oxygen before you guys got here okay and
that's because there's life on this
planet so that's scheme number two
scheme number three which is what we do
we turn we train big antennas on the sky
hoping to imitate Jodie Foster by
finding a signal coming from intelligent
species intelligence means you can build
a radio transmitter and you should
probably ask the person sitting next to
you hey can you build a radio
transmitter and you'll know what you're
sitting next to so how long's god this
how how long have you been at this what
somebody's been at this search for a
long time I mean it's in 1960 Frank
Drake did an experiment I've been afraid
trick who's Frank - Frank Drake Frank
Drake well Frank Drake is a an
astronomer he lives in Santa Cruz some
of you may have heard of Santa Cruz
he did the first accessor keep it weird
he did the first experiment along these
lines back in 1960 before most of you
were born was after I had reached middle
age 1916 he used an antenna in West
Virginia one emphasized that West
Virginia pointed at a couple of nearby
stars hoping to hear signals from et and
did he he did hear a signal turned out
to be the US military that did not count
as intelligence but it didn't have some
means to filter the US military from his
thing well they didn't give him all the
frequencies they weren't gonna be
broadcast oh so what why did he do this
for the very reason you brought up bill
everybody wants to know where they came
from and is anybody out there
the third question I notice you're not
interested in is where are we going
but one thing at a time yeah
and that's also another question I guess
that little kids ask right especially if
it's not McDonald's where we go where we
go why would we so you grew fascinated
with this at some point yeah you're an
astronomer yeah telescopes lot lots of
cheesy sci-fi films when I was a kid I
think because the aliens look and think
about it aliens are terrific bad guys
for the movies right when the Soviet
Union collapsed in 1991 you know all the
handy bad guys kind of went away but
aliens you can eat right now we have no
more enemies so that's good yeah
terrific but you know nobody I know I'm
glad there's no anti-defamation league
or anything for the aliens so they're
not going to complain and they don't
answer residuals I think so there are
many old questions associated with us
but why did you decide to do this with
your professional career well I was in
the city let me say in the sense you've
been looking for several years 1960 is
getting to be that was Frank Drake no I
didn't get into this until quite a bit
later 1981 I yeah okay since 81 what are
we now were some other big or not
yeah so you haven't heard anything is
American education system yeah hey I can
do a little bit of yeah look look but
the point is it's a special moment in
time I mean you know everybody thinks
they're living in a special moment of
time they probably thought that you know
in the year 1000 got is a special moment
I'm Bob because people are idiots yeah
I've never felt here 1,000 that is a
crappy year you know you can dowse they
had shoes maybe maybe they had shoes
definitely had lemons
and even that I'm like probably that's
right you have to be the right part of
the world they were Siberian witches
yeah yeah got the Black Death you know
look what's gonna happen in this century
that you're gonna see one is we finally
understand biology so a lot of diseases
you're worried about now you won't be
worrying about in 50 years the second
thing is we're probably inventing our
own successors for making Thinking
Machines I don't know how you feel about
that
unless you're I think how I feel about
it but that's this generation and the
third thing is we're gonna I think find
that you have some company out there how
do you say that now just the way it but
if you ask me oh I see
let me rephrase that for you you're I
takes it in the gut nicely done
nice well played doctor szostak no so if
I'm a seriously how what's the what's a
reasonable population of nearby stars in
distance of light-years well I mean if
you're interested in a thousand years
stars look the number says it again yeah
I'm sorry I keep saying that but they
can it's only the radio only it's cannot
it's the our galaxy our galaxy just
consider our galaxy the Milky Way galaxy
they're like a couple of hundred billion
stars couple hundred billion okay the
number of planets is probably close to a
trillion we then if within a thousand
light years that's not very far I got
that on my conduct a thousand light
years there are on the order of
millions and millions of stars okay so
here's what I'm sayin's to you we're
listening for one that has been
broadcasting for the last thousand years
right not necessarily but you have to
assume that if there are thousand
light-years away they broadcast
something there you know come join the
klingon book club or something and maybe
for only ten minutes and it arrives
today when you happen to be looking
that's good enough if we were to
broadcast something with our current
technology how long would it take for
somebody a thousand light years maybe a
thousand years that would be sent
meanings that's the speed sound would
travel or signals will they be the speed
of light but what a signal travel at the
site of light yes if it's a light signal
yeah oh you gene open up but what our
esteemed colleague what if it's like are
we only set up but are we only listening
for light signals is that what you're
saying well radio travels close this
beetle I'm just saying explain it to
someone who maybe didn't major in
anyways I'm hinting at it with my idiocy
so radio waves and light waves go to the
same speed aha I caught you in a piece
of information I like so but this you
guys this goes way back Dave no I was
just I actually heard you interviewed
recently where you said that we may have
gone silent now because we're all
broadcasting digitally and the digital
signals don't propagate through space I
hope I didn't say that it is true it is
true right I don't know how many how
many of you have rabbit ears on the top
of your TV set okay but I don't mean
from the club the thing is that what
we're shutting down the big towers you
know the red and white antennas on the
outside of town because in fact you're
getting all your information digitally
or you will soon enough you'll just have
a if you don't already have this you
have a fiber optic that comes in your
house you get your internet your TV your
phone some of you have this already
that's the way we're going so a lot of
TV broadcasting will go away that's true
but there is the but is that some things
aren't going silent like the radars down
at the San Francisco Airport you're
probably not going to shut those down so
we're moving a lot of right unless there
ain't no GPS
GPS is all in the hot 94.5 that's what's
going on now but this search for this
people have been fascinated this
fascinated with this for centuries yes
yes I mean people go back they'd see the
cities on the moon canals on Mars this
goes way back it does the ancient Greeks
thought about it too they thought
everything they could seen this guy was
inhabited were they all murdered we're
saying it out loud so this is when
thoughts were murdery
so but that was in Greece in Greece some
people they voted and they're
democracies and so but Seth why did they
think that you've given this some deep
thought it is to be expected I'm not
sure I have I haven't thought too much
about why the Greeks believed that the
Greeks were kind of upbeat you know they
figured you know we're here there's this
stuff up there they came up with nifty
ideas like the atom and geometry and
science he said that and he's right so
they couldn't be the only people that
had that idea no but they were the first
to perfect it they were just really
really good at it so first thing was
they you know the tunics were just
perfect for it first of all yeah
when you say tunics you mean togas
drapey a tunic number that your
slave-boy would wear so
all right of course but I'm talking
about people who were - who heard the
Greeks repeat about it right now but
Galileo then his contemporary Bruno the
Bruno was burned at the stake over this
business right well he was burned at the
stake that's true kind of a bummer for
Bruno but the batchi of dawn burner for
Bruno but but but the reason he was the
reason he was incinerated actually
wasn't because he said that there was a
multiplicity of worlds he did say that
so that was what the 16 1600 he was Oh -
yeah something like that
he was burned at the stake for
suggesting no not for suggest not they
burn him for a different reason they did
because they burned him for heresies
against the church sorry but so that was
saying there's alien life so one he's
like alien life and they're like fine
it's like your God not totally real not
fine you get the drift
yeah so he deserved to be burned this
way you're saying they did do a Bernie
thing yeah so Bruno did not have a
telescope dude did he look now Galilee
he was burned in 1600 Galileo turned a
telescope to the sky in about 1609 but
it was he influenced by Bruno's drama
Bruno flambe no I I don't I don't think
he I don't think he was no but this is a
case was this is a military instrument
keep in mind I mean Galileo wasn't
looking for life in space he he just
took this toy that came out of Holland
he didn't invent the telescope of course
Dutch probably of course he was the
first person to point it not at the
ground
yeah the first person I'll computed at
the neighbors that's we pointed up yeah
there's your whole tunic thing yeah
people are remarkably stupid name one
all right that guy
I'm just guessing you're not wrong so
Galileo looks at this thing and he did
he speculate that there was life on the
moon well you know in the beginning it
was just sort of astounded to find that
for example the moon wasn't perfect
because you know it's Robbie Jensen yeah
it's all beaten up and and you see these
dark areas and it kind of looked like
oceans and he thought well maybe maybe
maybe but it was actually got a name you
know Johannes Kepler I guess his buddies
called him John Kepler actually look I
always called him Cappy Cappy the
Kempster yeah he he thought he saw
buried cities on the moon I mean for a
long time the moon was believed to house
sentient beings named moon men I've
heard tell that even Utah houses
sentient beings so but I've seen no
proof but then this goes on for another
century Huygens comes along thinks that
there's life everywhere right
not Wiggins but Hershel maybe you mean
Hershel Hershel bill Hershel
it's just it's your list beauty always
sounds like you're saying probably the
greatest astronomer who ever lived
actually in that that's a big deal it
was no you know they don't ever get
Nobel Prizes well you have to make it a
sore spot Alfred Nobel was cuckolded by
an astronomers but really who was it
that little fact there who was it is it
under Celsius or some guy I don't know
but that's where we were talked about
Herschel Herschel thought there were
inhabitants on the Sun or just beneath
the the luminous layer of the Sun that
turns out to be wrong problem wait are
you saying he was the end he's the
greatest astronomer
I'm not denying it I'm just asking for a
second reason other than he thought
people lived under or in the Sun we call
it a follow-up in journalist yeah I know
that
signals are this anyway but I could go
number two and then you'd understand
yeah
okay the second greatest astronomer
without his shoes could sing opera what
true story really story I heard that
yeah I heard that heard on the radio
yeah well but what what was great that
Herschel did yeah I was gonna get to
that or Huygens Herschel Herschel
Herschel had a telescope good enough to
look at Mars everybody's favorite
inhabited planet Mars and he could see
the white you know polar caps at the top
and the bottom and you know the till the
caps are made of dry ice frozen carbon
there's some water ice but whatever I
mean has you know seasons because the
accident dry ice whatever anyway 25
hours he gave a talk to the Royal
Society I think was a 1784 1784 that's
just at the end of the American
Revolution 1784 and he says that the
Martians probably enjoy a lifestyle or a
climate at least rather similar to our
own really yeah he said that the Royal
Society but if we go there now it's 20
below on a summer day and there's
nothing to breathe which you would
notice that you you would you would
notice that and you can say the same
about certain times of year in in
Auckland not not anymore
but wait my question of so what was so
one of the so what makes him
particularly great is it that he was the
first to postulate or the first to look
at Mars or what was he right about he
person he sounds awesome
and he sounds creative but yeah what did
he was this ever like he sounds hi
I'm gonna tell you but this is too much
of a straight line for you that's fine
okay
he found Uranus I'll leave her be oh
yeah not trivial I prefer the old
pronunciation from when you and I were
children so these are telescopes from a
long time ago we have we have modern
telescopes and people look out there and
they they observe planets and they can
infer from here that these places are
probably inhabitable but what does it
take to be habitable well that's
actually a good question because all we
know is what it takes for life like our
own to be habitable so you have to start
there if you have any other data points
[Music]
necessary I mean if you dug a hole one
mile deep here take you all night but if
you did that and pulled up the muck at
the bucket do it in two hours okay
I dig it man if you did that and you
pull up the muck at the bottom you know
you can put it under microscope you'd
see you know microbes so don't need air
to breathe
they don't need air no photosynthesis I
mean they're alive but they're down
there so but the generally accepted I
mean there's no good definition of life
right you might think of Justice Potter
talking about pornography I'll know it
when I see it life is kind of the same
way right so it can definitely high-five
I think we can all kind of agree that
it's not life of it yet going yeah but
what else and you know what and if it
leaves you hanging it is dead to me
well sad day and so with that ladies and
gentlemen your if you're listening
you're listening to Sketchfest from San
Francisco at the Marine Memorial
Auditorium
Theater and this is Startalk radio live
and we will be right back
[Applause]
[Music]